well it looks like the royal rift is
only growing deeper
thanks to new bombshell revelations from
harry and megan's so-called journey
to finding freedom
i think they are very much in a pressure
cooker situation
burning their bridges and burying the
ashes professional victims
accused of being tone deaf and whining
the headlines show no mercy as h m's
critics say
this explosive book is torpedoing any
chances they had
of returning to the firm for the royal
family
yes this book has been damaging because
it has opened up old wounds
there's been crushing backlash even
though the book is not out until next
month
the authors quote the couple's friends
and confidants for the
incredibly detailed juicy stories such
as there was no kiss
on their first date and megan's phone is
loaded with selfies with harry
but a sussex rep says the pair were
quote not interviewed and did not
contribute
to the tell-all there is a lot of
speculation and that they may
also have spoken to harry and meghan
themselves
another new revelation it seems megan
may have tried to erase her past as a
deal or no deal briefcase model
she was on the game show in 2006 and
2007
but her wikipedia bio changed from model
to philanthropist
just three weeks before her relationship
with harry went public
finding freedom also makes accusations
of racism royal staffers calling megan
duchess different and paints a toxic
atmosphere with employees labeled vipers
scheming behind harry and megan's back
there was a feeling
at the palace that harry and megan were
becoming too big
and that riff between the brothers may
now actually become wider
now that so much royalty is being
spilled all over the palace floors
the problem with this book is that it
has busted open
that old and still raw wound
and at a time when it was just beginning
to heal
as for the frosty relationship between
megan and kate turns out
moments like this wimbledon girl's day
out might have been
just for show i was always told that
there was never a cat fight as such
between the two girls i was told that
they simply didn't
[Music]
click